so forgive us our skepticism when we
don't believe it there's something very
strange
going on here something extremely bogus
going on in our political system those
aren't my words those are elon musk's
words
who thinks that there's something
extremely bogus going on with
the way we're talking about coronavirus
we'll get to that in one second but
first
we got a lot of great content coming to
the daily wire obviously we're here in
nashville
we are we we have fled
governor nussolini in california which
was trying to kill our business
basically
we are building up our own place
in a in an area where we can breathe a
little freer we've got a lot new people
coming over we've got
candace owens our friend candace is
going to be coming over to daily wire
we're gonna be launching a new show with
her
we're gonna be launching new cultural
products we got a whole lot of new stuff
going on
the set is just the first part we are
building out things all over the place
come be a part of it with us i have told
you from the very beginning that i think
that the
public policies surrounding coronavirus
are completely bogus and stupid and i've
been ignoring basically all of them as
much as i possibly can and i encourage
all of you to do that as well
well now it seems like i'm being joined
by elon musk
in my skepticism of some of these
policies elon musk
just tweeted out quote something
extremely bogus is going on
was tested for covid four times today
two tests came back negative
two came back positive same machine same
test
same nurse rapid antigen test from bd
okay so that is weird that's pretty
weird right you get the exact same test
in the exact same place from the exact
same person and two of them come back
positive
two of them come back negative was it a
false positive it would seem to be
i guess could have been a false negative
but i think in the case of elon musk
it'd be false positives
so maybe we can't rely on that so much
maybe we can't rely on dr fauci who's
been wrong and changed his mind every
single step of the way
maybe we can't rely on these genius
andrew cuomo probably the greatest
example of this we're told he's the
most important governor on coronavirus
he wrote a book about leading through
coronavirus
andrew cuomo's policies killed thousands
of elderly new yorkers he handled the
virus worse
than any other politician in the entire
country
and we're told to follow him
why why what's the uh show me the
evidence
there there i guess there's some
evidence of some effectiveness of the
masks that we've got
we've quoted on this show
epidemiologists from colombia have
quoted this to
npr we've quoted cdc studies that show
that the masks are not particularly
effective
the one columbia epidemiologist said
that they're not affect maybe they would
be effective in a perfect world but
they're not effective in the way
that people use them because they touch
their face they wear them incorrectly
okay makes sense if you keep some filthy
cloth mask in your pocket for three
weeks at a time it's probably not going
to be all that sanitary right
well we now have more evidence that not
even the liberal elites pushing these
policies believe in them
as i have been suggesting from the very
beginning i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts